yeah I don't always do videos of a
first-look of a character in a movie but
a picture's been released by Zack Snyder
of Jason Momoa as Aquaman and we learned
one very important thing from it Aquaman
is a huge Sons of Anarchy fan joking
aside I think he looks really cool he
looks exactly how I thought Aquaman
would look when I heard Jason Momoa was
cast for I remember my video where I
talked about it I said something like I
feel like this Aquaman is gonna be woo a
hardcore I feel like he's gonna be
Aquaman but he's gonna look like the
forever evil cking Aquaman boom there
you go that's exactly what I had in mind
the honor scene looks a lot like 90s
Aquaman I guess in the 90s he looked
just like that only he had like a hook
for a hand I don't know much about it
cuz I haven't read it because I didn't
read Aquaman in the 90s are you kidding
me I still thought I'll go mad with
super lame but seriously though I have
no gripes about this yeah he looks
hardcore but I mean for all the
people out there who have not read the
Geoff Johns Aquaman they still consider
Aquaman a joke how are you going to
bring them over to the side of Aquaman
how are you gonna have Aquaman in the
movie net people or oh I was totally
awesome
yeah have them look like that you have
them go full L Billy deluxe I feel like
if people about this they're
bitching for the sake of bitching like
who looks stupid it's on the ground by
the head be like are you an Aquaman fan
really we're like no I actually don't
give a about Aquaman it's like
griping about things keyboard gets
lonely I need to type on it need to type
hateful things I know there are some
people who are Aquaman fans who
genuinely don't like the look of it cool
but a lot of people who are bitching I
just feel like this just of
everything gal gadot as Wonder Woman Ben
Affleck is Batman although I'm more on
the side of Ben Affleck as Batman now
bat flick every picture that's released
of the guy impresses me more and more so
I'm like I actually am down for that if
Zack Snyder pulls off the conflict
between Batman and Superman properly in
this movie could be really awesome but
Jesse Eisenberg as Lex Luthor of
everything that I have seen in a heard
about Batman V Superman or this Justice
League movie coming out did the Aquaman
thing is actually the thing I'm like I'm
not gonna grab out it's a hardcore
looking Aquaman is interesting
that the Geoff Johns Aquaman that I
really love it's Arthur curry at a timer
he's like it's kind of taking up the
throne of Atlantis but people are like
there's some friction and conflict
people who don't read Aquaman you don't
know that about Aquaman there's a lot of
conflict in there Atlanteans don't like
humans humans don't like it Lantern's
Arthur curry is he's both his mother was
queen
and now he's the rightful king of
Atlantis and there's a lot of conflict
there's like imagine Harry Potter worth
like half-bloods and you know pureblood
people ya know can't have any of those
mudblood imagine that kind of bigotry
among people in Atlantis who have a say
in the matter and Arthur curry is like
well I'm what you hate
I'm not a pureblood Atlantis was
actually it's a really cool relevant
story but I feel like in a world where
Aquaman looks like he's going full
dragula I feel like that's not actual
it's not where they are at this point I
feel like he's been the king of Atlantis
for about ten years now so yeah that was
back in the day now I'm here I'm wonder
if he's gonna be as diplomatic as he is
in the comic books you imagine a dude
who looks like that his life human
beings must be cherished at lanterns and
humans could work together everyone is
beautiful roundball king
mara is actually way more hardcore than
Arthur curry is there's a scene in the
comic book where this dudes giving her
like I hear when those atlante and
you're a dummy Lantern
and she started because she can
manipulate water she does what she does
just like a waterbender she starts
sapping the water from his guys like
water's coming out of his eyes and ears
look she's like yeah you're getting a
headache and then you're gonna get
really tired you're gonna go to sleep
and then you're gonna die you're like oh
my god Mara Mara Mara Mara
stop I just don't feel like that guy
would talk her out of it he'd be like do
it whatever you want his head to cool
right hey it's a spine I can tell you
this though in the Justice League comic
book there's this one thing with oh like
what on earth can you do and these
drones are coming after them in
Aquaman's raises his scepter all these
sharks just come out of the ocean just
tear apart these apocalypse baddies
whatever trailer features that Aquaman
whether it be Batman V Superman or
Justice League whatever trailer it is
you're going to see a scene like that
all power just shows his power the
Sharks are gonna jump out of the water
something badass is gonna happen you
guys gonna be like holy Jimmy was
right Jimmy was right I've
seen some people complain about the
coloring of the costume it's like it's
too gray I hate the fact that it's great
I want to say that that's probably a
poster thing I really hope it's not in
the movie like that
you tell him the armor and the gauntlet
there is gold in there you can tell it
in his pants if you take a look at his
pants it's okay I'm look where his dick
would be
it that there's green there look closely
I'll give you a second look closely look
at Aquaman's dick do we are you look at
his skin tonnage it is not that colorful
so really I feel like that is a poster
thing I hope in the movie it looks more
colorful so Jason Momoa as Aquaman what
do you think of his look whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more